[Music]
along with the seventh installment of a
very possible action franchise this week
brings the return of a popular show
about vampires a movie about summer camp
for thespians another season for an
anthology murder mystery series and an
rt25 pick with some great hairstyle
ideas for you it's time to drive a
motorcycle off of a cliff and parachute
to the bottom figuratively speaking of
course on this week's what to watch this
mission of yours
just you
dearly
dangling into theaters is Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part 1. there
are plenty of reasons to go on this
Mission the first of which being that I
don't know if you've heard but Tom
Cruise does his own stunts and this time
around they have one of the most
aggressive stunts not only in mi history
but movie history we're talking Tommy
Boy driving a motorcycle off of a cliff
into a base jump yikes another reason to
see this is that we can now officially
report that dead reckoning part 1 is a
big hit with critics with a certified
fresh score of 96 on the Tomato Meter
making it the second highest scoring
installment in the franchise just below
its predecessor 2018's Mission
Impossible Fallout and joining him on
the screen again are familiar faces like
Ving Rhames Simon Pegg and Rebecca
Ferguson with Christopher McQueary once
again serving as director and co-writer
and remember this is just the beginning
of the segmented story with dead
reckoning part 2 set to release next
year in 2024. thick and vampire sure man
I thought the transformation would be
over but it's been 16 days I can't turn
into a bat yet
human form emerging for a fifth season
is the mockumentary comedy series what
we do in the shadows born from the 2014
film of the same name this show has had
four very successful certified fresh
Seasons leading up to this one with two
coming in at 100 on the Tomato Meter and
the others not too far behind throw in a
couple of Emmy knobs for outstanding
comedy series and that's a great first
reason to give this one a shot plus the
series is still influenced by Jermaine
Clement and Taiko waititi who wrote
directed and starred in the film the
series was created by Clement with ytt
serving as executive producer and
occasional director along with Clement
on top of all that the series which
follows four vampire roommates in Staten
Island has already been green lit for
the sixth season as well so it's about
time you get out of the shadows and get
invested in the show welcome auditioners
you guys are so talented so unbelievable
this will break you this will fully
destroy you congratulations on being the
most talented kids again another option
for theater goers this week is the Indie
comedy flick Theater Camp and for the
First Act aka the first reason to see
this one I'll tell you about the
impressive cast that not only includes
Tony winner Ben Platt but two yet count
them two stars from the hit show The
Bear one is the film's co-star Molly
Gordon who also co-directed it alongside
Nick Lieberman in their directorial
debuts and the other is ioa debris in
his supporting role another reason to
consider attending this one is the fun
premise about the directors of a rundown
Theater Camp in Upstate New York who try
and put on a masterpiece of a show to
keep their beloved summer tradition
afloat the film premiered at Sundance
earlier this year and is currently
sitting at 77 percent fresh on the
Tomato Meter accompanied by strong 73
audience score it's the kind of combo
that deserves a standing o and the Bravo
I don't know theater stuff you get it
number one suspect is the bride Zoe's
sister
Grace didn't do it we got a dead body
and a whole lot of people to talk to
what's your name you fine as hell Travis
joining the fun with the premiere of its
second season is the Apple TV series The
After Party if you haven't seen this one
yet now is the time it's a murder
mystery Anthology series that's also a
comedy with each episode being told from
a different character's point of view
and a different genre which range from
animated to Thriller to Musical and
season one that cool and unique approach
is the first reason to see this one
another is the cast which includes
season 1 Stars Tiffany haddish and Sam
Richardson returning for season two but
with all new people around them think
Knives Out in Glass Onion that includes
names like Zach Woods John Cho Ken Jiang
Elizabeth Perkins and Vivian Wu and
while season one took place at a high
school reunion after party this season's
murder happens the day after a wedding
and speaking of season one it is worth
noting that it's certified fresh on the
Tomato Meter with a score of 90 and an
audience score of 80 as if you really
needed another reason to join this party
hi it's Ted I haven't seen you since uh
how's everything oh that's you're fine
and finally our rt25 pick this week is
the comedy film There's Something About
Mary not only is this movie which came
out 25 years ago this week a certified
fresh comedy which is no easy feat it's
actually considered one of the greatest
comedies of all time and especially the
90s we'll call that a pretty good reason
to revisit or just regular visit this
one plus the cast is fantastic from
stars like Cameron Diaz Ben Stiller and
Matt Dillon all the way down to a
special Cameo appearance from one of the
greatest NFL quarterbacks of all time
and if you don't know who it is when
they pop up you're too young and it's
past your bedtime and beyond the stars
in front of the camera is the directing
Duo behind it Peter and Bobby Fairley
The Fairly Brothers they were coming off
1994's Dumb and Dumber and 1996's
Kingpin when they made this one a short
yet impressive resume at the time and
it's gotten better from there
okay that's it five picks that are
really quite possible to check out and
hey if you want to live dangerously like
Ethan Hunt just use a friend's login to
watch some of these wink wink be sure to
let us and your fellow viewers know in
the comments what you did check out
whether it was on this list or not
remember to check out rottentomatoes.com
for the latest updates on scores and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large plus
there's more great Memory Lanes to go
down on our rt25 page that's all for
today fresh family until next week stay
fresh
[Music]
good